okay today i will tell you about this
very fascinating number four
two
zero
five
one four upon seven that's the fraction
now these are a special class of
sequences called somo sequences
and they go as follows this is really a
very fascinating story in general it's
called somos k sequences where k can be
a number so let's say you start from
somos 1 it's just a string of wants you
can predict that the algorithm is simply
a n plus one is a n
then
equals one
it's very very simple nothing magical is
happening here it's
very not interesting
now
somos 2 i'm going to give you the
algorithm and we'll look at the
sequences and there is a pattern in this
in this algorithms that will
that will get clear in a minute so once
i start writing enough of these you'll
go ah that's the algorithm and you're
starting from this and you're saying
a0
is 1 and since it's almost 2 which means
that a1 is also 1. if you want to
compute a2 your sequence right now looks
like this you have 1
and 1.
a2
will be
a1 times a1 divided by a0 which will
just be 1. now look at what happens for
a3 you get a2 times a2 divided by a1
which again
is 1. so
you can believe me that you only get
stream of months
now the sequence is not very interesting
but the algorithm is getting juicier now
let's go to almost three the algorithm
is a n is a n minus 1 n minus 2 divided
by n minus 3.
rc it is going to be a 0 is 1 a1 is 1 a2
is 1. all right so your sequence is
starting from three once now a3 is a2
one
a zero this is
one i'm getting pretty sick at once
well you need to wait slightly longer
okay so you have a4 now since you're
already sick of once you'll see another
one because you have a3
a2
a1
so sorry you have one again and one
again it'll continue to be a string of
ones now you see these are pretty boring
at the moment so
the statement is that the first three
uh terms of this this different somos k
sequences which means that's almost one
two and three are all the strings of
ones
nothing interesting happening but it
just gives you a feel of where the
algorithm is going now we go to summers4
well we see something interesting there
is the question
i hope the answer is yes
so the algorithm is
a n
is now i'll write it as a fraction okay
numerator is going to be a n minus 1 and
minus 3 plus n minus 2 squared
upon n minus four with a zero is one so
it now has a string of four ones in the
beginning and what numbers does that
spit out okay so a4 is going to be a3 a
1 plus a 2 squared a 0
1 plus 1 divided by 1 which is 2.
oh we got a new number exactly now
what's happening with a5 if you do a5
it's going to be a4
a
2 plus a 3 squared upon a 1
3. so things are starting to move
still integers though we're still
getting still integers
now look at this there is no reason that
this should give you integers right
so
let's do another one see if we get a
fraction yep that's that's the idea you
have a5 a3 a4
now you could say that i'm cheating
because all the denominators have so far
just been one
you'll say that
a bit longer because a2 is also 1. what
is this going to give us 3 plus 4
divided by 1 and you get a 7 7. we got 4
strings of 1 that was already given and
then you have 2 3 and 7. now let's go on
and maybe i will introduce you to the
first term which has a denominator that
is not 1 so that you know i'm not
cheating and maybe now you can take my
word for it that the next one will be
23. a 8
will be 69 plus 49 divided by 2. so you
have 118 divided by 2 which is 259.
you see even when the denominator is two
you still got an integer no fractions
yet no fractions yet
now this goes on this goes on for the
whole sequence that you'll never get a
fraction right and the next one is three
one four one thousand five two nine and
so on it's doing two things it's not
giving you a fraction
but the number is also growing it's
growing pretty fast
okay now you can say well that's a bit
too much of a coincidence
okay
one can check it and there is good
reason that it's not giving you a
fraction
okay now i'll introduce you to another
non-trivial thing and i won't go through
the computations but i'm guessing you
can believe me at this point yeah i have
earned your trust you have so much five
so you just start with five
ones
now you can see what's happening if it's
almost four it starts from four once if
it's almost five you start from five
once
and this is very important because if
you don't start with all ones then you
do get a fraction
but then it's not really somos it's not
really the magic of all these sequences
so if you want the magic
stick to the rule that first however
number
of ones you need to get you always need
to stick to that one it'll be
two and a three but it won't be the same
as almost four of course you'll get a
five and it'll go to
11 37
83
274
1217 and it goes on integers yep always
integers so it's almost 4 all integers 5
all integers
so what's really happening it's curious
enough that it's always giving me
integers but then the question is how
far is it going to keep giving me
integers does it break
is there some god-given rule what's
happening so
so mo 6 again all integers no fractions
so 7
all integers
no fractions
it's almost eight
something happens or not
that's the thing okay i'll just write it
down okay so most eight it starts with a
string of eight ones and what is the
algorithm
you have a n minus 1
a n minus 7 a n minus 2 a n minus 6 a n
minus 3 a n minus 5 a n minus 4 squared
divided by a n minus 8. so you see the
algorithms are also growing they're
growing very nicely but there's a nice
pattern going on there these are all
ones up to this point so what's the next
digit ah it is four now you go on you
have a seven you have a 13 25 61
187
775 5827
one four eight one five and this is age
16. still all integers still all
integers clearly i know what i'm doing
so what is the 17 digit
okay let's do it so you have the
sixteenth term times the tenth term
fifteenth times eleventh fourteen times
twelve thirteen squared divided by 9
which is
this term the last one times 13.
the next one is
5
5 8 2 7 times 25 so it's the term
before the last one times 25. now you
see the pattern you have the
multiplication of this multiplication of
this and the next one is 775 times 61
which is these two
and then there is 187 squared which is
sitting right in the middle
all divided by 7 which is a 9 which is
the guy here and that will equal 4 2 0 5
1 4 divided by seven and it's not
divisible by seven
so it's a fraction exactly the rule has
been broken ah no
we got so far yeah
that was the fraction you showed us at
the start of the video yeah and that's
the first fraction that appears in these
sequences ah
so the other ones when all the ones
before went all the way to infinity
without a fraction without a fraction
but in these almost eight sequence you
get a fraction
is that the only fraction no that's the
interesting part now you can continue
and you get
so let me write this down four two zero
five one four
we'll give this a special box because
it's the first fraction it deserves its
own box
and then you got 2 8
6 7 0 7 7 3
divided by 91. fraction
not an integer and this goes on you get
quite a lot of fractions
it's not very clear if you'll find an
integer somewhere but up to the first 30
digits or so you never get an integer
again all right okay so this is where it
breaks
yeah so what happens with somos 9 and 10
and 11
same thing you'll think you'll get
integers in the beginning but you'll
eventually see
fractions and there is an interesting
thing also about which term is a
fraction it's almost 8 the 17th term
breaks now what happens for somos 9 it
is the 19th term and for 10 it's the
20th term so it's almost twice as
whatever the number you're getting here
what happened what change that made it
break all of a sudden when it was doing
so well and always staying as integers
that's a hard question there is quite a
lot of deep understanding of
these the algorithms that i wrote down
those are very very important for
all sorts of things so for example the
somos 5 algorithm which was this guy
this comes out as some discrete integral
system that's the buzzword
uh so there is a good reason why
these are just integers
but i don't know why it breaks at a
higher order
but
when it doesn't break we have some
understanding of what's behind them so
there are these things called cluster
algebras which are associated to them
there is all sorts of very very nice
mathematics that is also very recent
so that's one of the reasons that these
are super exciting that's exciting that
number there 420
514 over seven the troublemaker yeah
troublemaker number or the trendsetter
oh yeah that's true as well yeah yeah
it's a more positive spin yeah yeah okay
the trend setting number for all these
sequences now i like trouble
okay
so there is this constant somewhere out
there
in the world of numbers
with this formula which will give you
every prime number in order as well not
missing one